la guerre se déroule avec des tanks des
avions de chasse mais aussi avec des
cyberattaques cette guerre asymétrique
parce que sans visage qui a déjà touché
le ministère de l'intérieur ukrainien
peut-elle s'étendre aux pays limitrophes
voir en france peut-on imaginer un effet
concret sur l'approvisionnement en
viande ou encore en pétrole comme ce fut
le cas l'an dernier aux états unis
guillaume grallet bonjour bonjour vous
êtes d'autres experts
cybersécurité la cyber guerre entre la
russie et l'ukraine a déjà commencées
oui alors c'est un peu une drôle de
guerre on pourrait paraphraser pour un
foyer pour désigner en fait ces conflits
asymétriques
1 vous l'avez dit vous avez des
puissances dématérialisé qui vont
s'opposer avec des dégâts virtuel ça
peut être des vols de données mais avec
des dégâts qui peuvent être extrêmement
réel et ça le ministère de l'intérieur
ukrainien s'en est rendu compte et bien
dans la nuit du 13 au 14 février il a
pointé du doigt notamment ce qu'il
explique être un nouvel épisode d'une
guerre hybride qui dure depuis que la
russie mène un combat contre l'ukraine
notamment dans lorsque le conflit dans
le donbass avec les séparatistes ce pro
russe a gagné en ampleur des accusations
qui a démenti formellement moscou
quelques elle est davantage d'avancées à
ce point masqué et bien on peut avoir
des effets stratégique extrêmement réel
sans en avoir la responsabilité
on peut faire passer d attaque comme
venant de
extrêmement naturelle de groupuscules
qui viennent de la société civile alors
qu'en réalité on peut manoeuvrer en
utilisant par exemple des groupes de
cyber mercenaires et là il faut se
tourner vers les recherches d'amnesty
international qui a révélé l'existence
d'un groupe comme void bas lors du nom
d'un monstre d'un mythologie aux
multiples têtes ça fait pas vraiment
rêver mais se montre ce monstre comme
l'expliqué le trend micro a des effets
bien réel dans sur la planète entière il
n'y a plus vraiment de frontières dans
les dents les attaques ont cybersécurité
tout ça ça me rappelle un petit peu les
attaques on a attribué un autre groupe
qu'on a dit venus de russie qui
s'appelait ray vinh et qui l'année
dernière a perturbé la distribution de
la viande du géant brésilien
bs l'approvisionnement on a été perturbé
et là et cet incident a été au menu de
la rencontre entre vladimir poutine et
joe biden c'était le 16 juin 2021 oui
cette guerre guillaume est aussi celle
qui joue sur l'émotion et la
déstabilisation
oui alors on a parlé tout à l'heure du
ministère de l'intérieur plusieurs
banques ukrainiennes en ont été victimes
pas moins de soixante sites web
gouvernementaux ont eu une vue sur leurs
ordinateurs des messages comme ayez peur
attendez vous au pire l'idée c'est
d'affaiblir dans les esprits le
sentiment de résistance et de cohésion
de la population plus inquiétant de
nouvelles cyber armes ont été
découvertes potentiellement beaucoup
plus dommageable oui alors c'est le
cloud terme hermétique à viper américain
viper va effacer les données et on a pu
observer ceux ci les chercheurs ont
observé cela donnait une centaine
d'ordinateurs à la fois en ukraine mais
également en lituanie ou encore en
lettonie issa trussardi lab explique que
énormément de données ont été effacées
c'est également le cas avec six clubs ce
cyclope louis va va combattre va effacer
les pare-feu vous savez ces sont les
mécanismes défense des ordinateurs qui
ont été mis au point par la société de
seattle watchguard
et les agences de renseignement
britanniques l'américaine attribue ces
attaques à au groupe sanlu worm un
groupe de hackers russes qui étaient
responsables de la deûle attaque notre
pays a contre l'ukraine en 2017 pourtant
guillaume en plus des perturbations
qu'elles provoquent ne ces cyber
attaques 1 peuvent-elles menacer
directement nos vies oui alors on l'a vu
en si on regarde un tout petit peu
l'histoire récente de l'ukraine on voit
qu'on peut avoir ce qu'on appelle les
attaques scada c'est à dire c'est des
attaques sur les infrastructures
critiques c'est elle qui en 2015 lorsque
des logiciels malveillants provoqué des
pannes de courant dans pas moins de sept
cent mille foyers en ukraine c'est dans
l'ouest de l'ukraine est en 2016 on
était en plein hiver et bien il ya des
logiciels qui ont coupé la capacité
électrique de la ville de kiev ça a duré
que quelques heures mais si ça avait
duré plusieurs jours et bien ça aurait
pu être mortelle surtout lorsqu'on voit
l'intensité de l'hiver on a vu également
alors ça c'est encore plus inquiétant en
2018 l'ukraine déjouer une intrusion
dans une usine de chlore qui était
destiné à propre et l'excès de chlore
dans la provision nous on se demande
quelle sera la prochaine étape y at il
justement des risques d'expansion de ce
cyber conflit plus près de chez nous par
exemple eh bien on bien sûr on se
demande si ça va arriver aux voisins de
l'europe ou à la france précisément et
pour répondre à cette question je vous
propose d'écouter les propos de nicolas
art patience et le responsable de la
cyber sécurité de l'éditeur de sécurité
informatique trend micro
les pays européens sont hautement
numérisés il utilise le numérique pour
commercer pour produire pour échanger
pour communiquer et donc il est
important d'avoir cette disponibilité
des systèmes d'information pour assurer
la continuité au sein des au sein du
pays c'est la raison pour laquelle
moscou pourrait être tenté si certaines
chancelleries était trop véhémente à son
goût de solliciter ces cyber mercenaires
qui pourrait conduire des opérations
ponctuelles venant à déstabiliser des
pays européens et leurs équipements
d'autant plus que la france est à une
période particulière avec l'élection
dont qui crée une fébrilité est il et
c'est la raison pour laquelle l'état est
particulièrement vigilant via l' agence
nationale de sécurité des systèmes
d'information à la protection des
informations critiques qui ont été
désignés injustement par l'état dans le
domaine aussi stratégique que le
traitement de l'eau l'alimentation la
banque les télécommunications notamment
et c'est l'objet d'une vigilance
particulière pour justement empêcher
tout dysfonctionnement qui affecterait
la collectivité nationale et comment
notre pays guillaume doit-il s'y prendre
pour se défendre au mieux et bien notre
pays compte heureusement sur certaines
sociétés extrêmement spécialisé c'est le
cas présent de wallix qui est basée à la
fois à munich ou encore à boston et qui
a été créé sur les modèles de dark trice
vous savez d'un retrait cette société
américaine qui compte dans ses rangs des
anciens du hem highfive de la cia
notamment et puis surtout on peut dire
que les puissances publiques prennent
réellement le relais on connaît bien sûr
l' agence nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information qui est monté
récemment en puissance on ne s'est dotée
également notre pays d'un cyber campus
un cyber campus qui doit détecter les
intrusions faire travailler les
chercheurs du public et du privé en même
temps l'itc ici c'est de devenir
chasseur de rançonneurs
on a enfin la création très récente de
vigie nous sommes un tout nouveau
service qui a été placée auprès du
secrétariat général de la défense et de
la sécurité nationale pour repérer les
opérations de désinformation là ça peut
être extrêmement clé aussi important que
que des dégâts matériels surtout surtout
en période d'élection merci beaucoup
guillaume grallet